[Musik]
viele menschen meinen behindert geistig
behindert und sie wollen sich im prinzip
mit solchen menschen nicht
auseinandersetzen
er war sechs jahre wo ich die bindung
bekommen hat und das hat mich irgendwo
stark gemacht
wenn viele sagen es geht nicht dann habe
ich gesagt das geht und es ist machbar
ich mache ja nicht ruhe auf baustellen
mit krücken alltag für weiter stuben
er ist chef und mitinhaber einer
gerüstbaufirma wo wir vor 19 jahren das
unternehmen übernommen haben von dem
altbesitzer war ich der einzige
behindert ich war aber damals die runde
gerechnet also um die 40 ja hatte vorher
das unternehmen das alt unternehmen hier
in sachsen schon ungefähr zehn jahre
geleitet
die banken sie natürlich grundsätzlich
vorsichtiger vor bei behinderten weil
sie nicht mehr wissen können die das
geld überhaupt was sie mal genommen
haben
zurückzahlen viele wo ich kenne die
ähnliche pylonen haben sind heute schon
im rollstuhl und dass er natürlich die
banken sehr vorsichtig kann der unser
geld noch langfristig zurückzahlen es
folgen schwierige jahre in denen er
insgesamt 400 mitarbeiter vergrault ich
war früher ein tyrann
ja
sie meinen mitarbeitern
das größte problem war einfach ich
musste mich behaupten
und behaupten habe ich mich damit
gekonnt dass ich natürlich meine
mitarbeiter zeigen musste wäre chef ist
teilweise thomas leif ich bin wieder
wasserwaage durchgegangen habe geschaut
ob das gerade steht und wenn das nicht
gerade gestanden hat dann hat zeigen
können dass sein arbeitsplatz verloren
hat so weit ist es gegangen also ich
musste mich aufgrund meiner erziehung
weil ich immer bis hin zu auch in der
erziehung nach von meinen eltern so ja
du bist behindert du kannst das nicht
und so muss ich mich halt immer beweisen
was ich kann das ich will dass
mittlerweile müssen seine mitarbeiter
ihn nicht mehr fürchten
stuber wurde milder seit er sich
erfolgreich etabliert hat also
entscheidend war mal richtig auf die
nase zu fallen ja also muss ich so sagen
und dann zu sagen hey ich habe hier auch
richtig scheiße gebaut also 2010 hatten
wir den auftrag angenommen
da haben wir uns trafen verkalkuliert
und 2012 14 in den jahren haben wir uns
komplett noch einmal neu aufgestellt die
firma hat sich im spezial gerüstbau
einen namen gemacht
stuber hofft vorbild für andere zu sein
denn unternehmer mit handicap gibt es in
deutschland so gut wie gar nicht ich
glaube dass menschen mit handicap
grundsätzlich ja mehr in die
öffentlichkeit gerückt werden müssen
also nicht unterstützen sondern mehr in
die öffentlichkeit gerückt werden
menschen die ein handicap haben dann
sehen sie die in der zeitung ganz allen
zitieren kann sehen fast nie ja und da
liegt das große problem dass die sich
teilweise auch nicht trauen nach vorne
zu gehen und zu sagen hier bin ich ich
habe ein problem aber ich bin soweit
geistig fit dass sie nun leben aufbauen
kann
stuber versucht immer positiv zu denken
erlittene diskriminierungen aufgrund
seines handicaps blendet er aus
er hat es auch gegeben ja die waren
teilweise auch schlimm aber ich es nicht
so dass ich mir jetzt die im hinterkopf
gemerkt habe und es kommt dazu
ich komme langsam io die 60 und ich
merke halt doch dass manche sachen
manchmal einige sachen aus dem speicher
rausfliegen